j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public direction la mer Rouge où les
attaques de rebelles yemménites contre
des navires marchands sont en train
d'asphyxier petit à petit le canal de
suè et donc de déstabiliser le commerce
mondial malgré les frappes
américaino-britanniques contre leurs
installations militaire les outils sont
toujours menaçants Jonathan du priez sur
ces images de vidéos surveillance un
missile frappe un navire marchant grec
cette attaque s'est produite il y a 6
jours la dernière en date en mer Rouge
revendiquée par par les rebelles
yéménites outis depuis l'éclatement du
conflit entre Israël et le Hamas ces
rebelles solidaires de Gaza ont
multiplié les exaction envers des
navires ayant un lien avec Israël face à
ce péril une coalition emmenée par les
États-Unis et les Britanniques frappe
sans relâche les positions outil depuis
le mois de
décembre ce matin les forces américaines
ont mené avec succès trois frappes
d'autodéfense contre des cibles outil au
Yémen il s'agit de la 4e action
préventive menée par l'armée américaine
au cours de la semaine écoulée contre
des lanceurs de missile outil prêt à
mener des attaques la coalition veut
urgemment endiguer la menace outil qui
pèse sur le commerce international car
les rebelles contrôlent une importante
façade maritime proche notamment du
détroit de babelmandb un couloir
maritime où transite 20000 navires par
an soit 12 % du commerce international
les outils soutenus et armé par l'Iran
ne compte en aucun cas reculer sous la
pression des
Américains les forces armées yeméni outi
confirment que la réponse à l'agression
américaine et britannique est inévitable
et que toute nouvelle agression ne
restera pas sans réponse ni impunité les
outils posent leurs conditions pour
cesser les attaques en mer Rouge il
réclam un cesser le feu et la levée de
ce qu'il nomme le siège israélien de
Gaza mais à ce stade les États-Unis
restent sourd aux revendications d'une
organisation qualifié de terroriste
est-ce que les frappes arrêtent les
outils non et est-ce qu'elles vont
continuer la réponse est oui de son côté
la France refuse toujours de participer
aux frappes préventives de la coalition
craignant une régionalisation du conflit
entre Israël et le Hamas en mer
Rouge qui sont les outils ces rebelles
yeménites qui défilent l'Occident qui
menace le commerce mondial réponse avec
Agnès Levallois bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes vice-présidente de l'Institut de
recherche et d'études Méditerranée
Moyen-Orient Franck Mernier bonsoir et
bienvenue anthropologue spécialiste du
Yémen directeur de recherche au CNRS et
auteur de ce livre Yémen écrire la
guerre aux éditions classiques Garnier
Patricia léonier bonsoir et bienvenue
Patricia grand reporteur spécialiste des
relations internationales et je cite
votre livre au cœur du chaos publié aux
éditions
au Mathieu croissandau évidemment est
resté à mes côté rebonsoir Mathieu
question toute simple mais réponse
sûrement complexe à diè Levallois euh
qui sont-ils ces rebelles yéménites
quand on dit les outils qu'est-ce qui
vous vient spontanément pour les définir
alors c'est une milice qui donc est née
au Yémen dans le nord du pays et qui est
très active maintenant depuis quelques
années dans la suite du mouvement de
contestation en 2011 qui a vu la chute
du président SALH et les houtistes ont
réussi à prendre la capitale Sana et
donc ils sont aujourd'hui un acteur
majeur de la de la de la crise et du
conflit qui vit que vit le le Yémen avec
une volonté en fait d'avoir un rôle
politique dans la suite dans l'après
guerre puisque actuellement il y a des
négociations avec les Saoudiens pour
tenter de mettre un terme à cette guerre
qui ravage le pays depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années et donc les houtistes
profitent aussi de cette occasion pour
s'imposer encore plus sur la scène
intérieure et pour en bénéficiant
finalement par leurs attaques d'un
soutien encore plus grand en interne
parce que ces derniers temps ils étaient
un peu contestés par une partie des
yéménit qui ne les soutient pas en gros
il représente mais ça Franck sera
peut-être plus précis un/3 de la
population yéménite
h teroireourdhu et il entendent jouer un
rle significa dans la guerre il y a
aussi un enjeu intérieur dans ces
actions et alors juste pour préciser les
sont aussi ils sont ils appartiennent à
une branche de l'Islam les
zaidites préantion voilà et souvent du
coup on a tance à dire que ce sont
desites donc proche de l'Iran mais c'est
plus compliqué que ça plus compliqué que
ça et puis alors il y a une histoire de
d'où vient leur nom fr mais il y a une
histoire familiale c'est une his au
départ c'est un clan familial est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça comme ça alors au
départ c'est un village qui s'appelle
hou au nord du Yémen et donc le premier
de enfin le plus connu de la famille
c'est badreddin Al hi donc le badreddin
qui vient de Housin c'est son nom de
famille en fait et donc ça a donné euh
naissance à un mouvement clanique d'une
certaine façon au départ avec les
différents membres de la famille surtout
les fils de badeddin alhousi qui était
un savant religieux zeidit donc de cette
qui était aussi descendant du Prophète
c'est important à à signaler dans la
sociologie de du de de des mouvements
politique au Yémen c'est justement
cette c'est le fait qu'il y a eu un
mouvement de renaissance zaïite euh dans
les années 90 au Yémen dans les années
80 et 90 au Yémen et qui a été mené
notamment par les descendants du
prophète qui avaient été durant l'époque
de l'imama finalement les mettes à bord
au Yémen dans une grande partie du Yémen
donc si je Simp
pardon je vaisêtre totalement béoien
mais il y a c'est un clan familial qui
se qui qui se réclame du prophète qui
descend du Prophète c'est un clan qui
descend du du Prophète donc par Ali et
Fatima enfit c'est assez précis et
Hassan et Hussein donc c'est
véritablement un clan familial et qui a
qui a donné le nom son nom a donné le
nom au mouvement au départ il y avait un
autre nom aussi
c'est c'est-à-dire les les partisans du
slogan au départ parce que leur slogan
très connu aujourd'hui c'est mort à
l'Amérique euh mort à Israël malédiction
sur les Juifs et victoire à l'islam ça
dieu est grand mort aux États-Unis mort
à Israël maudit soit les Juifs et
victoire de l'islam voilà et et ensuite
en 2011 comme a été ça a été signalé par
niè le Valois donc il y a eu ce
mouvement de contestation au Yémen qui a
abouti à la chute de Ali Abdallah Saleh
et les les h ont participé et ils ont
euh donner un nom plus disons politique
à leur mouvement qui se qui s'est appelé
ensuite depuis 2011 les anar Allah
c'estàdire les partisans de Dieu les
partisans de Dieu euh Patricia lémonère
ce sont des religieux et des guerriers
oui parce que cette ce groupe familial
en quelque sorte hein qui qui appartient
le Yémen c'est très particulier c'est
vous en parlerez surtout mieux que moi
mais il y a trois grosses fédérations de
tribus en fait qui se voilà et eux
appartiennent effectivement donc à une
fédération et il faut dire que le
président salé avait installé dans leur
région en fait des gens qui n'étaient
pas du tout appartenants à leur à leur
pensées religieus qui était
effectivement plutôt de la tendance
salafiste ou des Frères musulmans et à
partir de là c'est déclenché des guerres
si vous voulez parce que c'était c'était
une une implantation incongrue dans une
zone en fait qu'il contrôlait
familialement donc il y a eu toute une
série de guerres et les guerres ont
commencé finalement il y a eu 94 puis
les années 2000 puis après le fameux
soulèvement du printemps arabe don par
la niè et puis après la conquête de Sana
et cetera et en fait cette cette donc ça
fait quoi ça fait deux plus de deux
décennies trois décennies quasiment qui
sont en guerre voilà et donc cette cette
milice est en fait ce parti est en fait
c'est en fait forgé à travers sa
croyance mais aussi à travers ses
guerres et et jamais ces hommes n'ont
cessé de faire la guerre donc ça ça
donne une structure assez particulière
que je dirais qui est très
militaropolitique mais je parle sous
votre supervision agès Levallois de quel
Islam on parle alors c'est c'est c'est
un islam rigori j'ai dit ça en titre
mais qu'est-ce qu'on dit derrière ce mot
en fait les zaidit donc c'est une
branche des chites et c'est pour ça
qu'on les associe immédiatement à l'Iran
mais c'est un islam zaïite au Yémen en
tous les cas qui a toujours été quand
même assez proche de l'islam sunnite
beaucoup plus proche que de l'islam dire
et ça veut dire donc que dans le terme
des des pratiques si vous voulez il y
avait pas du tout d'opposition où
l'opposition n'était pas marqué comme on
a pu le penser entre ces zaïites et le
reste de la population yéménite qui elle
était sunnite et donc cette opposition
qui a été souvent mise en avant n'est
pas une opposition qui correspond
véritablement à la réalité de la
pratique de cet islam dans ce pays qui
est le Yémen oui d'ailleurs an si je me
trompe pas mais à l'intérieur d'e d'une
même tribu il peut y avoir des chiites
et des sunnites oui alors moi je repose
la question et par exemple est très
basique la place des femmes par exemple
elles ont elles ont le droit de sortir
elles sont voilées totalement voilées
elles bon si on parle des du mouvement
houi par rapport justement à la place
des femmes euh on voit qu'ils qu'ils
sont très rigoristes sur ce plan
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont euh créé des
lois justement pour euh d's on séparer
encore plus les hommes et les femmes
notamment à l'université euh notamment
sur les lieux professionnels et cetera
donc ils sont euh et ils ont même créé
une milice féministe qui s'appelle
féminine plutôt pas féministe mais qui
s'appelle les zeinabiat donc de Zeinab
c'est-à-dire donc toujours en lien avec
euh la la descendance du de Ali et qui
sont
euh et qui sont en fait chargés de
contrôler les meurs et les femmes le
corps des femmes notamment et donc le
évidemment pas parler du port du voile
parce que cela c'était déjà assez
répandu au Yémen avant avant l'arrivée
des rousises mais il est vrai que les
rousis ont un un projet de de de
changement culturel de la société
yeménite qui est assez important et
qu'il faut qu'il faut signaler et qui
n'est pas tout tous les yéites justement
ne sont pas d'accord avec ce projet et
ce ne sont pas d'accord avec ce projet
des hotis de par les contraintes sur la
vie sociale alors les liens entre ces
Rebell outil et l'Iran voilà ce dont on
va parler maintenant dans notre débat et
je vous propose pour lancer ce chapitre
d'écouter le secrétaire d'État
américain bon pour lui c'est très clair
derrière les frappes des houti il y a
l'Iran hier nous avons eu l'attaque de
drone la plus importante ces attaques
ont été soutenu et encouragé par
l'Iran en terme de technologie
d'équipement de renseignement et
d'information Patricia lmonère à quel
point ces rebelles houtil sont sous
influence iranienne j'emploie ce terme
volontairement oui c'est vous faites
bien l'employé d'Ille effectivement
volontairement parce que en fait je
crois que leurs liens sont encore plus
forts et plus une proximité très forte
avec le hzbollah Libanais mais nous y
reviendrons certainement le le lien avec
l'Iran est évident
immédiatement halhouti enfin celui qui a
été assassiné enfin on va dire assassiné
qui tué était allé à Rome avec son frère
pour faire ses études et cetera en Iran
donc il y a une une une une proximité de
la famille vis-à-vis de l'Iran et puis
après l'Iran et bien effectivement
qu'est-ce que l'Iran s'est dit il s'est
dit que dans cette dans cette tentative
de si vous voulez de de circonscrire en
fait finalement son ennemi qui est
Israël les outil avaient un rôle a joué
dans la mesure où les Saoudiens étaient
les alliés des Américains et donc il y a
là effectivement un intérêt de l'Iran
dans son positionnement stratégique dans
la région ce qui est intéressant enfin
moi je trouve c'est que les Américains
jusqu'à présent jusqu'à ce qu'ils que
les outils se manifeste de cette façonlà
les Américains ne s'intéressaient pas à
ce conflit il s'y inéressaient même sils
étaaiit dans dans la devise très
clairement désigné comme il sraitait le
conflit aux Saoudiens oui et ils
s'intéressaient au début il son inér à
la zone que parce qu'il y avait alqaïda
dans la péninsule arabique islamique et
donc là c'était pour faire leur frappe
d'ailleurs salé c'était ài enfin c'était
rapproché des Américains donc les
Américains portent aussi une
responsabilité géopolitique parce que
ils n'ont pas du tout tenu compte ils
ont ce qu'ils font d'habitude ils ont
délégué la gestion du conflit à leur
voisin je reste sur l'Iran avec vous
agès Levallois prennent-ils leurs ordres
à thérant je pose des questions
volontairement un peu un peu simpliste
mais ça permet de savoir quel est le le
lien de subordination on va dire entre
ces rebelles yemménites et l'État
iranien aujourd'hui moi je ne dirais pas
que les houtistes prennent leurs ordres
auprès de l'Iran les houtistes ont une
autonomie une vraie autonomie une marge
de manœuvre dans les décisions qu'ils
prennent euh ils ont bénéficié au début
de la guerre au Yémen après la
révolution de 2011 ils ont bénéficié
d'un soutien des Iraniens il y a eu un
certain nombre de d' de de de gardiens
de la révolution qui sont venus au Yémen
pour les aider pour les entraîner donc
il y a eu une coopération et qui les a
aidé aussi a fabriquer des missiles des
drones donc ils ont bénéficié de cela
mais ce qui ne veut absolument pas dire
que les Houtis prennent leurs ordres à
Tran ils ont leur propre agenda un
agenda intérieur et un agenda sur la
scène régionale et les Iraniens ont vu à
un moment aussi l'intérêt qu'ils avaient
évidemment à travailler avec ceci mais
de penser que les Houtis sont une milice
aux ordres des Iraniens je crois que
c'est une erreur Fran merm qui se passe
depuis plusieurs semaines donc c'est ces
attaques menées par par les les les
rebelles outils contre des navires
marchands dans euh dans dans la mer
Rouge euh est-ce que ça permet quand
même à l'Iran de de mener une guerre par
procuration moi je dirais d'abord qu'il
faut savoir que le le slogan rousi dont
on a parlé là avec Mor àamérique Mor
Israël maistion sur les Juifs et cetera
il est né en après le 30 septembre 2000
lorsqu'il y a eu la mort de deux
palestin enfin le le les les tirs de
soldats israéliens contre un père et son
fils palestinien et le fils a été tué et
c'est à partir de ce moment-là que husin
alousi celui qui a véritablement fondé
le Mouvement donc le fils de badreddin a
créé ce slogan donc il y a déjà départ
un lien très fort avec avec avec le
conflit en en Palestine en Israël et
donc ça c'est important à souligner dans
le même temps son père husinousi qui a
créé ce slogan lui-même avait été dans
les années 90 en Iran pour s'échapper à
la pour échapper à la répression du
régime yeménite ali Abdallah saler donc
il y a véritablement un un lien
idéologique et là il a été influencé
évidemment par les slogans de la
révolution iranienne par le programme de
la révolution iranienne et donc le le
mouvement rousi en fait s'inscrit dans
cet axe de la résistance où on retrouve
le Hezbollah l'Iran les milice irakienne
chiit et les housis et donc d'une
certaine façon ils s'inscrivent dans
cette axe mais avec un programme ou euh
yéménite c'estàdou j'entends j'entends
l'autonomie le fait qu'il ne prent pas
le leurs ordres Mathieu mais avec quand
même un moi je trouve un degré de
sophistication dans le matériel
militaire ils ont quand même été
capablebl d'envoyer des missiles à 2000
km parce faut rappel au téléspectateurs
que la distance entre le Yémen et Israël
c'est pas non plus la porte à côté ils
ont des drones relativement sophistiqués
tout ça c'est fourni et payé par l'Iran
en fait il y a il y a il y a de la
contrebande effectivement en mer il y a
eu des rapports de l'ONU qui on qui
démontré que qui ont démontré qu'il y
avait effectivement l'arrivée la
fourniture de matériel militaire par
l'Iran évidemment il y a des conseillers
aussi des gardiens de rtion des et et
ils ont les capacités en fait de les
assembler sur placeant et donc c'est
pour cela que il y a beaucoup de sites
plusieurs sites de missilees de
lancement de missile ou d'assemblage de
missilees qui ont été visés par les par
les Américains ou les Britanniques
justement en raison de ces capacités qui
sont importantes et qui sont en fait une
une façon mais en dans le même temps on
a bien vu que leurs drones ou leurs
missiles ont quand même une un pouvoir
de nuisance très fort mais une
efficacité quand même qui reste limitée
par rapport à d' P alors puisqu'on parle
des des des armes je vous propose de de
revoir ces images qui datent du 20
novembre des des des outils qui se
filment même hein c'est évidemment ce
sont des images de propagande donc on
les prend avec beaucoup de de pincettes
et de recul mais il s'attaqueent à un
navire cargo qui s'appelle le Galaxy
leader qui est affraé par un groupe
japonais mais le propriétaire est
israélien et donc il filme l'assaut et
ils arrivent en hélicoptère ensuite on
va regarder ces images prendre
le le l'équipage du cargo en en otage
voilà défilet avec le avec leurs armes
et cetera image de de propagande ce qui
est frappant c'est le voilà l'arrivée en
en hélicoptère et on va entendre le
patron d'une société de sécurité
maritime pour lui ce jour-là les moyens
qui sont utilisés et peut-être aussi la
tactiqu des outils sont surprenants
c'est une première ou une nouveauté en
tout cas écoutons Coré ranslem
lorsque le galaxie leader a été détourné
l'assaut s'est fait par hélicoptère nous
n'avons jamais vu les outils utiliser
ces tactiques par le passé nous
assistons à des frappes de drone et de
missiles nous n'avions pas vu ces
tactiques par le passé au niveau où nous
les voyons aujourd'hui il s'agit donc
d'une attaque complètement différente
par rapport à ce que nous observons
aujourd'hui contre les navires
commerciaux dans cette région
spécifique Patricia lon qu'est-ce qu'on
sait de leurs armes de la puissance de
feu de de ces rebelles yménites bah ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'on essaie de
décrypter c'est qu'effectivement comme
on l'a dit précédemment ils ont été
formé et assemblé sur place mais ça date
c'est c'est ancien c'est-à-dire cette
montée en puissance de la connaissance
ne date pas d'il y a un an ou de 2 ans
c'est très ancien et donc la
sophistication de leurs techniciens et
de leurs ingénieurs est très forte et
quand on va à Sana et quand on rencontre
des gens appartenant donc au partis qui
dirigent la capitale du Nord en tout cas
et bien on se rend compte à quel point
on a affaire à à des gens qui sont
totalement structurés avec un
commandement et et qui dirige vraiment
le pays d'une manière très autoritaire
d'ailleurs et qui ne laisse pas là
récemment il y a eu plusieurs procès
hein pour tous ceux qui voulaient
s'opposer ou même critiquer comme
faisait allusion à agès de Valois donc
ils ont les moyens et et ce que je
trouve ces moyenslà étaient détectable
avant parce qu'on le voyait très bien il
frappait aussi l'Arabie Saoudite donc on
voyait leur capacité moindre mais là
leurs capacités sont devenu ce sont
quand même des missiles balistiques qui
sont tirés ouis d' d'où vient leur
richesse est-ce qu'ils ont la main sur
le la production de gaz ou de pétrole
pay de gaz et de pétrole non parce que
effectivement le gaz et le pétrole les
champs pétrolifè et gaziers sont sous la
sous le contrôle du gouvernement
légitime c'est-à-dire celui qui est
reconnu par la communauté internationale
qui qui est aussi entre Aden et Riad
parce que là aussi il y a des problèmes
internes à l'intérieur du courant
gouvernemental donc il y a aussi une fr
tion à l'œuvre et donc ils ont en fait
euh peu de moyens locaux c'est-à-dire à
part évidemment le contrôle d'
contrebande mais ce qui est très
surprenant lorsqu'on on parle avec des
des des personnes qui sont allées à San
récemment notamment des yeménit c'est de
de voir que les que les magasins
regorgent de de de de produits venant du
golf et cetera faut savoir qu'il y a
évidemment la frontière maritime qui
peut servir à la contrebande mais aussi
la frontière avec Oman la frontière
terrestre avec Oman où il y a aussi
beaucoup de contrebande h agès Levallois
le je reviens aux images qu'on a vu là
ce ce ce premier navire cargot donc le
propriétaire était israélien les cibles
parce que depuis il y a eu beaucoup
d'attaques est-ce que les cibles sont
effectivement forcément ou uniquement
israéliennes ou est-ce que finalement ça
s'est élargi dans la dans la stratégie
des outils pour fragiliser ce ce cet axe
majeur du commerce mondial alors dans
leur déclaration il est dit clairement
qu'ils ne veulent attaquer que des
bateaux qui sont qui appartiennent à des
isram en ou qui ont un lien avec Israël
parce que l'objectif c'est vraiment de
viser Israël mais ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'il est très compliqué finalement de
faire la part des choses puisque des
navires peuvent app partir les
Israéliens mais sous pavillons autres et
vice-versa donc il peut y avoir des
navires qui sont attaqués sans forcément
un lien visible avec Israël même si dans
leur déclaration il est bien dit que eux
leur objectif c'est de pas de mettre à
mal le commerce international mais de
vraiment viser tout navire qui a un lien
avec Israël parce que là ils sont très
cohérent je par rapport à leur leurs
propos et leur propagande et l'objectif
qui va l'atteindre sauf que les
conséquences sont là en matière
économique on va en parler tout de suite
avec avec Steve Jourdain qui peut nous
nous rejoindre de nouveau sur sur le
plateau de ce sens public rebonsoir
Steve donc on on l'a dit c'est un point
névralgique du commerce mondial qui esté
oui on va voir des cartes on va voir
beaucoup de cartes on va on est dans le
D3 de Babel Mandel qui Bab elmand Deb
j'espère que je prononce bien qui sépare
Djibouti du Yémen sur la péninsule
arabique c'est un un des troit de 27
petits kilmètr seulement on parle
pourtant d'un des couloirs maritimes les
plus empruntés au monde 12 % du commerce
mondial transit par ce détroit chaque
jour 80 cargo et pétroliers font le lien
entre l'Europe et l'Asie les tankerss
passent par ici pour ensuite remonter
vers le canal de suèe et déboucher sur
la mer Méditerranée sur le marché
européen en 2018 3,5 millions de barils
de pétrole il transitait chaque jour et
donc on est directement concerné par ce
qui s'y passe oui c'est pas pour rien
Thomas que ce dtroit est très surveillé
c'est l'une des zones les plus
militarisées au monde nous avons nous
Français une base militaire à Djibouti
qui accueille environ 1300 hommes les
armées américaines chinoises italiennes
espagnoles japonais sont aussi
positionné dans la zone l'objectif c'est
de sécuriser cette artère cruciale du
commerce mondial d'autant plus que selon
Washington sur les 32 attaques menées
par les outils jusque là et bien la
majorité on visé des navires qui
n'étaient pas destinés à Israël mais à
d'autres pays alors depuis le début des
attaques on l'a vu au au mois de
novembre la dernière partie du mois de
novembre quelles conséquen sur le
commerce mondial alors les premiers
effets sont déjà là en ce moment 200000
conteneurs contenant des marchandises
transit chaque jour par la mer Rouge il
en avait 500000 au mois de novembre la
chute du transport de marchandises dans
la région se lie aussi dans les chiffres
du canal de suè les expéditions de blé
via le canal ont chuté de 40 % sur les
15 premiers jours de janvier selon l'OMC
c'est l'Égypte he qui accuse le coût
puisque le pays est très très dépendant
des revenus du canal de Suise moins de
passage c'est moins de taxes moins de
taxes c'est moins de revenus pour les
caisses de l'État en fait beaucoup de
compagnies maritimes on va le voir ont
choisit de contourner la mer Rouge et
ont choisit de prendre un itinéraire al
alternatifs les navires passent vous
voyez par le capâ de Bonne Espérance en
Afrique du Sud ça coûte plus cher aux
entreprises et c'est pas sans
conséquence sur les délais de livraison
écoutez vous avez un allongement tout
simplement des temps de livraison de
tout ce qui nous vient de fournisseurs
asiatique vers l'Europe donc il faut
savoir que en moyenne il faut compter
une dizaine de jours de plus de transit
lorsquon lorsqu'on contourne par
l'Afrique plutôt que de passer par le
canal de suess premier impact très
direct de la situation la compagnie
Tesla a annoncé suspendre saette
production en Allemagne pendant 2
semaines raison invoqué les importants
retards dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement et puis au total je
vous donne ce chiffre un Thomas le
commerce international aurait chuté
d'1,3 % au mois de décembre à cause de
l'augmentation des délais de livraison
d'autres entreprises pourrai également
être touché dans les prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup agè Levallois je me
tourne vers vous pour parler de l'Égypte
à quel point ça fragilise l'Égypte ce
qui est en train de se passer oui
l'Égypte est fragilisé parce que une des
des quatre ressources de l'économie
égyptienne ce sont les revenus du canal
de suè donc si le trafic est perturbé
dans le canal de Sue ça a une incidence
directe sur l'économie du pays à un
moment où cette économie va très mal et
il y a une grogne sociale qui va
grandissant et donc pour l'Égypte la
question est absolument centrale et en
même temps l'Égypte ne peut pas se
permettre de dénoncer ce qui est en
train de se passer puisque l'opinion
publique en Égypte est quand même plutôt
du côté des Palestiniens des Gazaouis et
donc l'Égypte se doit siici est quand
même sur dans une situation un peu
délicate et qu'il se doit de faire
extrêmement attention mais les
conséquences économiques et sociales
sont lourdes pour l'Égypte puisque cette
ce pays est vraiment confronté à un défi
vraiment très grave de la part de cette
situation économique et sociale Patricia
est-ce que la Rost américaine a a
affaibli les outils on a on a parlé de
dizaines de frappes sur des
installations militaires américaines et
britanniques d'ailleurs évidemment elle
les a affaibli mais le problème de ce
genre de de ripost c'est que tant que
les que le les outil ne disent pas bon
on arrête autant qu'on ne voit pas
visuellement qu'effectivement le leur
CAP capacités sont affaiblies c'est
comme Gaza j'ai envie de dire tant qu'on
ne voit pas que il n'y a plus de de
missiles balistiqu qui sont tirés et
bien que doit faire l'Amérique augmenter
sa riposte parce que qui veut
dire attaquer et essayer de détruire les
outils si eux ils disent ah bah oui on
arrête comme ils le disent le jour où on
a cessé le feu à Gaza tant qu'il n'y a
pas de cesser le feu donc et tant que
leurs capacités ne sont pas vraiment
diminués bien l'Amérique ne peut enfin
les États-Unis ne peut faire qu'une
chose continuer continuer et donc
augmenter et c'est bien l'engrenage et
c'est bien le problème d'aujourd'hui
c'est où cela conduit et on ne voit pas
du tout la stratégie américaine dans la
région parce qu'il n'y a pas de parole
possi avec les outils et donc on voit
pas où cette stratégie de frappe conduit
par contre on voit très bien où cette
stratégie conduit l'Iran parce qu'on
peut se poser la question si l'Iran n'a
pas envie en finalement de déplacer
cette ce qu'il avait mis en place dans
le golfe Persique c'est c'est-à-dire
cette capacité de nuisance et cette peur
de capacité de nuisance sur les bateaux
dans le golfe Persique pour assurer
assumer et assurer sa dominance s'il ne
veut pas l'exporter justement à cet
endroit-l Fran je vous pose la même
question peut-être qu'il est impossible
d'y répondre mais que sait-on de
l'efficacité des frappes américaines sur
ces installations militaires pense que
c'est très difficile de savoir quelle
estefficacité réelle de ces frappes ceci
dit depuis mars 2015 l'aviation
saouienne a ess d' bombarder énormément
les positions rousistes avec les Émirats
on a vu que finalement le les rousistes
se sont renforcés au fil de cette guerre
he depuis 2015 et et dans le même
temps ces attaques américaines
finalement renforce entre guillemets la
la légitimité aussi des rousis
c'està-dire légitimité
populaire tous les opposants au rousist
qui sont nombreux hein parce que même à
l'intérieur des zones contrôlées par les
rousistes aujourd'hui personne n'ose
critiquer justement le l'action des
rousis en mer Rouge donc c'est c'est à
part les le mouvement séparatiste
sudiste au sud du Yémen qui lui euh
souhaite en fait avoir un rôle comme
gardien de la sécurité en mer Rouge ou
dans euh la le le golfe d'Aden euh pour
finalement obtenir euh l'indépendance du
Sud Yemen donc là c'est un véritablement
une stratégie propre de pour pour pour
pour ce pardon vous interrompe ça fait
gagner je encore une fois je suis un peu
peut-être basique dans ma façon de
formuler mais ça fait gagner des points
aux Rebel outil au sein de la population
yéménite ce qui est en train de se
passer DEP plus semainant plus que
finalement les outils bah il mettent en
action ce qu'ils ont dit c'est-à-dire
depuis 20 ans ils disent qu'ils sont
contre les Américains contre Israël
contre l'impérialisme aujourd'hui ils
ont saisi l'occasion de confronter
directement et militairement surtout euh
les États-Unis et Israël donc pour eux
finalement c'était l'opportunité à
saisir d'autant plus que considérant le
territoire assez profond du Yémen une
superficie assez grande il est très très
difficile finalement de de pouvoir
affaiblir militairement les ousis sur un
territoire aussi large c'est-à-dire
c'est on est carrément de l'ordre de la
superficie de la France donc c'est
extrêmement difficile vouz inter oui je
dirais juste aussi que il gagne sur un
plan intérieur mais il gagne aussi sur
un plan internation na ils se font les
porte drarapeau pratiquement du combat
du Sud global qu'on définit très bien
face à l'Amérique béigérante et qui
agresse en permanence ils deviennent ils
reprennent le flambeau en quelque sorte
aujourd'hui du Sud global face à
l'Amérique sauf que les conséquences
économiques dont on parlait il y a
beaucoup de pays dans la région qui
aimeraiit peut-être que ça s'arrête
quand même à niè Levallois et qui bon
évidemment vont pas s'en charger parz de
l'Égypte on pourrait citer d'autres pays
de de de cette région du monde bien sûr
parce que tous les pays de la région
sont concernés par cette tension puisque
ça fait monter les primes d'assurance et
donc le coût pour le transport augmente
de façon considérable ça met en
difficulté et bien nos économies aussi
en Europe parce que nous sommes
directement touchés les pays de la
région également donc tout le monde
aimerait que ça cesse et on voit bien
que les Saoudiens dans cette histoire je
trouve que le comportement des Saoudiens
est aussi très intéressant parce que les
Saoudiens sont en guerre contre les
Houtis maintenant depuis 2015 Fran
MERMIER le le rappel il y avait une
coalition arabe et l'Arabie Saoudite éta
vraiment et toutes les les attaques
partaient du sol saoudien et donc avec
une volonté d'en finir avec les les
htistes que les Saoudiens depuis
maintenant quelques temps souhaitent un
accord de paix parce que cette guerre
leur coûte très cher alors
financièrement parlant bien sûr mais
aussi en terme d'image parce que depuis
2015 ils ont lancé cette guerre sans la
gagner face à des houtises qui sont
jeallis dire que des rebelles avec un
matériel beaucoup moins sophistiqué que
le matériel dont dispos les Saoudiens
qui eux-mêmes sont alimenté par les
Américains et donc on est face à une
situation où les Saoudiens aussi ne
veulent pas trop s'emmêler parce que eux
leur priorité ça d'arrêter la guerre au
Yémen et donc ils veulent surtout pas
que cet épisode qui est la lutte des
htistes contre Israël à travers les
attaque dans la mer Rouge mett en
difficulté cette négociation qui est
entreprise maintenant depuis de longs
mois et qui est absolument vitale pour
la crédibilité du prince héritier
Mohamed B Salman donc on a là donc ça
rend le Yémen enfin Rebell til également
plus fort dans cette négociation avec
l'Arabie une raison supplémentaire pour
continuer de d'attaquer ces nav
absolument et lestis pour eux la
priorité évidemment c'est d'incarner
cette résistance à Israël et de soutien
au Palestiniens et au Gazaoui en
particulier mais leur priorité aussi
c'est de gagner le plus de gains
possible en interne dans la négociation
politique visant à mettre un terme à la
guerre au Yémen alors on va parler de
cette coalition internationale qui menée
par les États-Unis
et les Britanniques donc a notamment
peut-être les frappes les plus
spectaculaires c'était le 12 janvier 70
frappes aériennes on l'a évoqué contre
des des installations militaires outil
explication de l'ambassadrice
britannique à l'ONU elle était devant le
Conseil de
sécurité nous avons pris des mesures
d'autodéfense limité nécessaires et
proportionné au côté des États-Unis avec
le soutien non opérationnel des Pays-Bas
du Canada du Bahrain et de
l'Australie
la Royal Air Force du Royaume-Uni a mené
des frappes ciblées contre des
installations militaire utilisé par les
rebelles outils au Yémen cette opération
a veillé tout particulièrement à
minimiser les risques pour les
civil bon là aussi on a peut-être pas
forcément beaucoup de moyens de vérifier
si les risques on été minimisés pour les
v mais que je voudrais vous demander
Mathieu c'est pourquoi la France
ne s'est pas uni à ses alliés américains
et britanniques dans dans ses opérations
au Yémen on le sentiment qu'à Paris la
question qui prévaut aujourd'hui sur le
dossier outil c'est jusqu'o ne pas aller
trop loin et le président de la
République qui est aussi le chef des
armées a d'ailleurs été interrogé sur ce
sujet lors de sa conférence de presse
regardez la France a décidé de ne pas se
joindre à une coalition qui a cherché
enfin qui a conduit des frappe
préventive contre les til sur leur sol
pourquoi précisément parce que nous
avons une posture qui cherche à éviter
toute escalade mais nous sommes présents
pour préserver la liberté de navigation
et d'ailleurs nous avons interrompu
missiles et drones qui allaient
frapper des navires norvégien et donc
nous agissons pour protéger nos propres
équipements et les équipements de nos
alliés donc nous agissons mais le cadre
c'est pas un sujet militaire c'est un
sujet diplomatique et pourquoi nous le
faisons parce que nous sommes vigilants
et attentifs au équilibres de la région
et au fait qu'il ne doit pas y avoir
d'escalade on voit refuser l'escalade
être vigilant aux équilibres de la
région c'est une prudence en tout cas
dans les mots qui tranche avec les
précédentes prises de position du chef
de l'État sur le dossier outil notamment
le 21 décembre dernier Emmanuel Macron
avait qualifié la menace de
d'intolérable la menace outil et les
attaque sur sur sur les navires
évidemment dans la mer Rouge 3 semaines
plus tard changement de ton on
l'impression que Paris euh temporise
d'une certaine façon comment
expliquez-vous cette prudence ben
au-delà du risque d'escalade et de
gestion des des équilibres avancé par
Emmanuel Macron il y a aussi des raisons
qui tiennent à la géopolitique et
notamment ne pas laisser la France
s'aligner sans restriction ni mesur sur
une position américaine de frappe
préventive qui engagerait notre pays
directement dans le conflit ne pas être
dans le camp des bigérants ne pas se
retrouver avec la France àord la France
avec à côté d'amord les États-Unis àord
Israël et c'est en plus y a une forme de
de dissensation par rapport à cette
initiative américaine qui a été annoncée
un peu en fanfare le 18 décembre avec
une vingtaine de pays qui devaient
rejoindre cette coalition et puis
beaucoup de pays qu' ont fait marche
arrière ou compris leur distance depuis
oui pourtant Mathieu la la marine
française on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
elle est présente en mer Rouge oui avec
notamment la frégate le longdoc he on en
parle beaucoup mais la France s'en tient
pour l'instant à une attitude défensive
en assurant au côté d'autres pays pour
le coup la surveillance et la protection
des navires attaqués par les outils
c'est-à-dire concrètement en
neutralisant des missiles ou ou ou des
drones quand ils arrivent mais on est
dans le cadre d'une forme de légitime
défense d'une certaine façon légitime
défense de la liberté de circulation et
non pas une position agressive et puis
plutôt que de suivre les États-Unis là
pour le coup Paris est en train
d'essayer de pousser à une initiative
européenne cette fois-ci de vigilance et
de
surveillance de de de la mer Rouge reste
une dernière explication plus prosaïque
celle-là qui est quand même celle de la
logistique et des moyens et faut le dire
parce que ça coûte cher une intervention
militaire et déjà très engagé en terme
de soutien matériel on en parle beaucoup
sur le conflit en Ukraine notamment et
ben la France rushing a engagé à
s'engager sur un nouveau théâtre sans
doute aussi par faute je vais commencer
par ça Patricia lonier effectivement
l'armée française a-t-elle ou
aurait-elle les moyens de
s'engager au côté des Américains et des
britannique euh je pense qu'elle a quand
même les moyens de faire aussi bien
peut-être que les Britanniques si vous
voulez en terme de
mais je crois surtout que là Emmanuel
Macron a regardé l'Europe aussi parce
que quand on voit en Europe les
européens en particulier les pays du Sud
l'Italie l'Espagne traînent les pieds ne
veulent absolument pas du tout entrer
dans ce genre de coalition donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a cette cette
proposition de force européennees pour
quand même faire quelque chose par
rapport à la navigation parce que c'est
la navigation qui compte 72 % je crois
que de nos de nos importations
européennes passent qui viennent d'Asie
du Sud-Est passent par ce fameux d trit
donc c'est quand même énorme mais on
veut en rester à cette position liberté
de navigation parce que c'est un
sentiment qui prévaut aujourd'hui en
Europe on ne s'implique pas et vous
savez qu'une des obsessions du Président
c'est quand même de maintenir la
cohésion européenne même si parfois il
s'y prend pas tout à fait bien alors je
vais rappeler quand même la devise des
des outil dieu est grand Mor aux
États-Unis Mor Israël maudit soit les
Juifs et victoire de l'islam agès
Levallois ça devrait suffire à mobiliser
une coalition occidentale pour je vais
être très trè trivial faire le ménage
dans dans la région oui mais on sait
très bien que c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait le ménage dans la région justement
et que donc la France aussi est tout à
fait consciente que de d'agir au côté
des Américains et des Britanniques dans
cette affaire alors que la position de
la France n'a pas toujours été très bien
comprise dans les pays de la région
après le la dénonciation évidemment du
massacre du 7 octobre mais l'alignement
considéré complètement sur la position
d'Israël aujourd'hui la France qui a
repris une position considérée comme
plus équilibrée c'est-à-dire de faire
attention de ne pas être complètement
dans la roue des Américains et bien je
pense qu'il s'agit aussi dans cette
affaire de montrer que nous avons notre
propre stratégie et que nous ne sommes
pas justement à 100 % au côté des
Américains qui eux-mêmes sont à 100 % au
côté des Israéliens donc il y a cette
volonté quand même de faire très
attention parce que les critiques ont
quand même été très fortes au début du
positionnement de d'Emmanuel Macron sur
cette question il nous reste quelques
minutes dans ce débat et je vais poser
un peu la même question à tous les trois
sur le le le risque d'escalade c'est un
terme qu'on a employé quand on a fait un
débat sur le hzbollah on peut le le le
le se poser la question évidemment elle
est centrale aussi à propos de ces
rebelles yéménites votre avis là-dessus
franc MERMIER en fait il faudrait savoir
aujourd'hui si quelle est la parce que
les les rebelles routi ou le mouvement
routi il est pas totalement il a il y a
des dissensions en son sein aussi il y a
des une ligne dure une ligne un peu plus
modérée donc il faudra savoir dans les
prochains jours quelle quelle ligne va
prévaloir c'est si c'est la ligne dure
de ceux qui veulent
justement continuer la lutte contre
Israël et donc empêcher le la navigation
commerciale en mer Rouge ou si c'est
celle qui est prête à un compromis et
qui notamment s'est révélé par les
négociations avec l'Arabie Saoudite donc
c'est c'est cette question là qui est
aussi en jeu aujourd'hui Patricia lmier
votre avis risque d'escalade l'escalade
bon moi personnellement je n'y je n'y
crois pas je n'y crois pas pour pour
deux raisons parce que je pense que même
si les outils ont une marge de manœuvre
très importante vis-à-vis de l'Iran
l'Iran détient quand même les canons de
la Bourse et les Canon des du de de
l'approvisionnement
donc l'Iran s'il veut j'ai d il veut
exporter son son modèle de coerition
navale qu'il fait dans le Golf Persique
en mer Rouge mais il veut pas forcément
faire plus donc je ne crois pas ça et je
crois que les Américains sont engagés
dans un dans une escalade dangereuse
mais je crois que eux aussi ne veulent
pas donc on a quand même les deux les
deux ferdolence en fait de ce conflit
avec les outils au milieu qui qui qui
qui veulent quand même retenir retenir
au maximum le risque d'escalade et d'
exposion de régionalisation sans parler
de l'Égypte et de l'Arabie Saoudite
évidemment et de tous les pays de la
région qui n'en veulent surtout pas donc
bien évidemment il y a il y a il y a la
donnée intérieure il y a le désir parce
que ce n'est pas eux qui ont le pouvoir
au Yémen il faut bien dire le Yémen est
coupé en deux entre lesouti au nord et
les sudistes et des des agrégats de
tribus donc ils veulent peut-être
profiter de ça pour descendre dans la
partie sud ou regrouper on n est pas
làin j'entends cet argument AG personne
ne cherche ou intérêt à un embrasement
la région mais on est quand même sur une
de crête le risque enfin qu'est-ce qui
pourrait déclencher ça je je veux pas
être un oiseau de mauvaise augure mais
c'est une question c'est exactement ça
la question je pense que personne ne
veut de d'une extension de ce conflit
d'une régionalisation du conflit on voit
bien chacun des acteurs était quand même
extrêmement prudent que ce soit l'Iran
que ce soit les Houtis que ce soit le
hzbollah il y a une prudence évidente
même les Américains dans leur façon de
d'agir donc personne n'en veut mais on
ne peut Absolum pas exclure le dérapage
c'est-à-dire l'incident qui va faire que
tout va échapper à tous ces stratèges où
qu'il soit qu'il soit à à sanara ou
qu'il soit à Terran ou qu'il soit à
Washington et que à ce moment-là la
situation échappe complètement moi ce
qui me frappe quand même c'est le côté
pour l'instant en tous les cas de la
part de ces acteurs régionaux qui ne
veulent vraiment pas que ça aille trop
loin mais en même temps ils sont tous
tenus aussi par une question de
crédibilité c'est clirant quand même qui
a tenu des grands discours de soutien au
Hamas se doit d'être les qui soutiennent
aussi le Hamas se doit d'être cohérent
dans sa façon de de de faire coïncider
les déclarations et les actes et donc
chacun est dans cette stratégie
finalement mais on ne peut absolument
pas exclure le dérapage même si moi je
ne crois pas au risque à ce stade en
tous les cas d'extension du conflit à
l'échelle région oui on a on a listé
finalement tout ce qui expliquait
l'action des outils depuis plusieurs
semaines dans cette dans cette région
dans dans la mer Rouge et et et et
dedans on a mis évidemment le soutien au
Palestiniens mais à quel point c'est
important d'après vous c'est constitutif
en fait de la de la fondation du
mouvement h c'est-à-dire c'est pas
cosmétique pas c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout slogan un slogan et et on
pourrait ajouter même si on peut revenir
à l'histoire immédiate aussi 2003
l'invasion américaine c'est-à-dire qui a
beaucoup évidemment choqué les yeménites
en général et et et le fondateur du
mouvement housi
c'estousi et donc tout cela fait que
on parle bien sûr du zidisme du fait
qu'ils sont que beaucoup sont
descendants du prophète dans leur cadre
dirigeant et cetera mais dans le même
temps c'est quand même fondamentalement
un mouvement politique c'est aussi un
mouvement
politiqueé proximité avec les mouvements
palestiniens avec les mouvements
islamistes chiit ou hein bien sûr et
donc qui s'inscrit dans ces Tex en fait
de politique chiite que qui qui s'est
formé en fait finalement l'Iran a eu
l'heureuse surprise de voir tomber dans
son escarcelle sans ce qu'elle l'avait
prévu une grande partie du Yémen
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui une autre
capitale arabe est devenu finalement
sous l'influence de l'Iran c'est S mais
c'était pas du tout prévu au départ et
il y a souvent eu de grandes
manifestations de soutien au palestinien
par le passé au Yémen et c'était un des
pays où il y avait la plus forte
mobilisation populaire vis-à-vis de du
mouvement palestinien donc cette cause
raisonne particulièrement chez les
Yéménites et les htises dans leur quête
aussi de soutien au-delà de la
communauté qu'ils aimeraient obtenir
d'être le Fire de lance aujourd'hui du
soutien des Palestiniens au Yémen est
important dans leur stratégie alors là
interne merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
qui était passionnant je vaiser les
titres de vos livres Patricia allemonère
au cœur du chaos livre publié aux
éditions
to et Franck MERMIER Yène écrire la
guerre aux éditions classiques Garnier
merci encore je vous donne rendez-vous
demain 18h 22h pour un nouveau numéro de
de sens publici et puis noter que
l'invité de la matinale demain ce sera
Nicolas du poinignan le président de
Debout la France face à Royan manciné à
8h du matin bonne
[Musique]
soirée